walk and i thank you
ah no lì no cash stringere per chi non
conoscesse residenti vol 4
mamma mia infanzia brutta che c'è allora
per me è stato il presidente 4 va bè
ragazzi abbiamo finito il residenti 12 è
stato molto figo il sistema si sa se
riguardate la perché veramente [ __ ] c'è
una parte le sentivo 2 che la gente sta
provando a farci la speed run è
praticamente to comandi un tizio e in
dieci minuti vi pare riuscire ad uscire
da una zona veramente incasinata perché
piena di zombie e ai dieci minuti per
farlo proviamoci però allo ragazzi non
ne sono veramente sicuro di quello che
sto per fare però proviamoci so che è
veramente difficile perché molte persone
non riescono
io stesso ci ha provato una volta sola e
non sono riuscito a vedere ci sarà un
sacco di ansia quindi se soffrite di
ansia wrobel gene non guardate questo
video dalla seriamente che c'è un'ansia
tremenda io stesso piero un infarto pro
pazienza mister morte di chiave in ti
vergogni può già partire è già partito
il tempo perfetto 17 secondi dieci
minuti per finirlo no no no no non è a
tempo ma io pensavo fosse a tempo che
allora non era tempo non ho dieci minuti
per finirlo però la gente vedo che
finisce in 10 minuti sono nelle fogne
devo fare tutto il giro è arrivare nel
nella centrale di polizia ed uscire da
qua
il che è veramente un casino non so se
riuscirò a farlo da zio
perfetto dovrei tentare di non sprecare
colpi visto che è molto molto difficile
molto difficile perfetto già l'ansia
cielo adesso perché se siamo all'inizio
e ragazzi con acqua di quanta piano devo
fare dei giri immondi per arrivare dove
deve arrivare devo fare dei giri
pazzeschi questa roba che ho
preghiamo non ci sono oggetti da trovare
ragazzi devo fare tutto con le mie forze
che forza ciao michele schivati ecco
come non detto
se per caso mai giù bravissimo ciao
ragazzi state pure lì io vado avanti
dagli allo schifo vita mamma mia che
brutta zona spento aspetto lui camier
vista aprendola alle 5
no forse non devo prendere 50 che non è
così
è uno stanzone orribile naja o pasta
sempre tu hai rotto le balle esplodi
esplodi un modo veloce veloce lo que sto
morendo sto morendo entra la porta la
porta guarda allora il piano deve uscire
dalle fogne
devo uscire dalle foglie devo andare di
qua il bello è che all ho giocato
talmente tanto sto residenti voi che so
esattamente dove devo andare ma c'è chi
già qua comunque non hanno arrivato la
prima volta che ci ho provato e ci sarà
un motivo
ragazzi sto cercando di risparmiare più
colpi possibili perché poi dopo
veramente un casino e ve lo dico ti
prego dimmi che non devo far fuori
questi ti prego ti prego 2 aiuto lo sa
sposare un'altra cosa ricordi carife
ricarica rigori con il prefetto se
riuscisse in qualche modo a distrarlo
non so come se col accecante può essere
guarda o fa tutto quello che volevo fare
non l'ho fatto
c'era granata ho sparato all'acqua però
va bene perché non mi hanno beccato e
che va benissimo
ciao stupore di un attimo di pausa un
microsecondo vi prego ascensione
perfetto siamo siamo neanche a metà
siano faremo al 30 per cento sicuro sono
mezzo acciaccato mi fa male lo stomaco
però vorrei ora il mal di pancia mi
piace come anno sincronizzato la musica
di sottofondo nel momento stesso in
questura l'ascensore minimi ritorna
l'ansia un gesù madonna ciao dei buoni
soli grazie perfetto non servono a
niente stai gran altro ho dato da
mangiare più granate oggi che perfetto è
riuscito a farli fuori non ho più
granate mi sa però non è una sola
fratelli miei non so come va a finire
sta faccenda però io come dovrei fare
spiega mi dai lui no è impossibile
minchiate botta è vivo è morto ucciso in
volo che culo via via via velocissimo
però aiuto mi chiamano male che me lo
ricordo a memoria
c'è un altro leaker sul soffitto non
facciamoci prendere da questa
complimenti fa vj bravo ce l'abbiamo
fatta siamo siamo nella stazione di
polizia
se voleva state perfetto ora se c'ho
voglia di vivere vado farcela guardiola
l'ufficio est a noi dopo passa di qua
dalle scale è poi va dall'ingresso
celico tecnicamente si spera mi ricorda
dove si passa di qua come spiegò me down
forza sparargli allo zio ma mi ha dato
tantissimo pensavo peggio
stai lì è perché per favore grazie non
ci credo sia non ci non ci voglio
credere che chi sa che cartone in bocca
ciao fratello madonna vai vai veloce non
stanato incredibilmente vai è
difficilissimo poi tra l'altro non so se
si può diminuire si può diminuire la
difficoltà di sta roba non credo o
demonio corpo morto ti spari in bocca
mori doppia doppia e una manciata di
spalle grazie ma solo da ciano le mie
spalle di così buono non sono morto
nostro saluto per mi sono curato un
millisecondo prima di ricevere solo
morso sono vivo per miracolo
vai resto già fatta
apriti porta veloce
aprite la porta aprite la porta guarda
tempo la porta naja la morte dovevo
andare scusami ma non ancora ma basta
poi si fa e la porta quella era la porta
quella era la porta era quella la porta
mannaia vesco non c'è l'uscita non c'è
l'uscita dove vado c'è un citare poi
alla portano esco scusami può fare tutto
il giro
salve mi stia ferma
fatti grazie da pacchi guarda sono
ancora vivo per miracolo
devo fare il giro dalle scale cosa che
non farò perché muoio prima però ok che
ho fatto non abbiamo siete scemi come
com'è possibile effetto lo stato si
ragazzi difficilissimo
non so da che parte andare giuro devo
andare di qua io vado nell'unica le
leoni che porte che si aprono sono
quelle giuste però non ho capito dove
dovrebbe essere l'uscita devo fare il
giro i quad alla libreria devo passare
si va beh no no ma tra fatte fatevi pure
i cavoli vostri per carità avrebbero
seriamente come come come come spiegano
i co me cose che giro devo fare adesso
intanto sono morto lega come mi
colpiscono una volta sono morto
io faccio la provata di turno non ci
avrò mai sono in rosso tipo che mi sputa
ne sono morto
cadono cose a caso
mamma mia ragazzi questo era poi io
quando tornavo a scuola quando avevo
tipo le carte rari di pokémon tutti i
miei compagni così dovrebbe morire è
morto effetto c'è ancora dieci colpi
lista pistola fortissima ma non ho vita
e zoppica e ciò una sacca bruttissima
aiuto e vabbè tanto guarda potreste
morire tutti ce n'era uno dietro che non
si sarà uscito sono ancora vivo come è
possibile
com'è possibile sono ancora come vai vai
velocissimo
e niente troppa gente va bene va bene mi
arrendo mi arrendo mai stato veramente
difficile però ci ho provato questo è
mio massimo che giro devi fare
incredibile per uscire cioè non so dove
passare da lì ha forse dovevo fare tipo
il giro deve uscire laddove entrata
clero in casinò ci riprova l'altra volta
ragazzi teniamo solo i momenti
divertenti
vediamo cosa esce dai dai dai dai dai
dai mai nello spezzatino massima vai tu
perché chi è giocato da tutti
fai tu fai tu preferita di due giocatori
non so qualcos'altro non si stornano non
lo studi neanche a morire io sono studi
toglietevi basta basta meglio pero corso
basta basta via però morso basta
ok sono andato avanti dal punto di prima
ma l'asta granata qua è finta la granata
la grata usa usa usa a granata non ha
usato la granata
impossibile non so come si faccia a
finire st parte ragazze è veramente
difficile ragazzi basta vorrei ammazzare
tutta la capcom è veramente euforica
questa parte è veramente fuori
seriamente ero quasi alla fine ma quello
il mio massimo è veramente difficile
ragazzi vi sia piaciuto ci abbiamo
provato è un po difficile ce la si può
fare se non hai una ragazza i ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto l'assenza di
questo momento mi piace anche verità
cioè come nota descrizione se non siete
ancora iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo qualche altro morso di zombie o
cose del genere bella ragazzi
[Musica]